may is national fitness month so for
this month so vegas i'm giving you vip
access to an exclusive boxing gym for
elite vegas talent check it out
las vegas the greatest arena on earth
and no matter what professional stage
you're performing on taylor berry will
get you ready in the ring
good control the distance off that
good my clientele is
not your average clientele so privacy is
key and in true vegas fashion these
vegas greats have the password to an
exclusive boxing speakeasy my exclusive
clientele is about 50 to 60 pro athletes
from about 25 raiders guys like darren
waller cleveland farrell
trayvon mullen and then going into guys
in that nba like that like vegas local
zach collins
mlb players world heavyweight champion
tyson fury and entertainers like steve
aoki that doesn't happen overnight
though the berries have been in boxing
for generations my granddad was the
olympic coach for new zealand
my dad was an amateur boxer he went to
84 olympics my granddad guided my dad to
a silver medal
my dad never turned pro he got into the
room of coaching and managing
professional box uh professional
fighters my dad's obviously had a lot of
success at the highest level many world
champions
and uh straight out of high school he
kind of offered me
you know to be his assistant and i kind
of grew from there but what brought
these new zealanders to vegas vegas is
the mecca of boxing and now taylor is
modernizing the mecca the old school
boxing vibes is photos from
you know the bottom of the wall to the
top of the wall
you know gloves all over the gym shoes
all over the gym kind of tape around the
bags
you know hundreds of degree heat in the
gym where our gym is a little different
you know as you can see i have a
aesthetic in here it's kind of
very
very clean to the eye that i wanted to
create a space where athletes felt very
very comfortable but i also wanted to
create a space that also had a bit of
swag to it
so i had strength and conditioning the
recovery room the physio section
and yeah so the gym's evolving i'm
adding some cold pools hot pools and
hyperbaric chambers for all the athletes
all the new bells and whistles but with
classic boxing principles boxing is one
of those sports where you have to be
completely switched on for every minute
of every round and i feel like
the way i train my athletes transitions
a lot into their own sports preparing
for those big moments those big moments
in the ring on the field or on stage
steve's not labeled a professional
athlete but his lifestyle was very very
hard you know he goes from miami to
vegas to la to chicago to all over the
country and all over the world he came
in here and started off once a week now
he's in here three times a week and i
feel like it just prepares him for when
he's on his tours you know he's uh
moving around a lot and it just keeps
them fit taylor says over the last year
and a half his formula has proven to
work it's all about fundamentals fitness
and friendship it's about
being composed but also having like that
relaxation kind of side to you
so i feel like when guys come in here
it's all about the energy and the vibe
and just having fun with what we do and
although his gym caters to local vips
taylor berry boxing continues to bring
the world
to this vegas ring so this is joseph
goodall he's an undefeated heavyweight
boxer from australia joe comes to vegas
because one the competition here in
vegas is the highest in the world you
know that in order to be great you have
to come to a spot like vegas
to improve and get better across
the level of competition here is like no
other it's
you know it's high level guys everywhere
you go in every corner jeff
right hand roll
oh that's awesome where is it oh i can't
okay all i can say
is that it is in henderson that's all i
can say that narrowed it down that's all
i can say henderson here i come yo when
i when i step foot in that gym i felt
like i felt elite i was ready yeah i was
ready but you can keep up with taylor
berry boxing at taylor berry on
instagram he posts everybody that's you
know walking into the gym and shout out
to my brother reggie he produced the
music for that story
because i couldn't give taylor just you
know a basic beat and give him something
good that's good stuff good stuff